today is a very very special day a
fantastic fabulous fan of the five
Robert Conrad is celebrating his
birthday is 83rd birthday today and we
call him Uncle Bob we got this little
special message from him for from Wild
Bill his friend who is also just thinks
he's fabulous he's at a legendary life
and a TV career spanning over five
decades and he's best known for playing
Secret Service agent James West in the
wild wild west and real-life World War
two fighter pilot a spa P boynton that
in show confused me I Wild West was my
favorite show but it could use me
because of that technology in the West
all these little tools he was the
original MacGyver that's what a great
loved him so much and he's not done Greg
because he currently hosts a weekly
radio show on CRN digital talk radio
happy birthday Uncle Bob we love you